when your father died it was really
devastating to you you were there in
Houston you were on your scholarship for
the flute and everything snapped and you
say [ __ ] this [ __ ] the scholarship I
can't I can't do this right now
and you literally are living out of your
car yeah what the hell was that like I
mean what is it like for you to be
living in a car and I bring this up
because I think people see you now and
go oh she's rich and she's lucky and
she's this has nothing to do with luck
the struggle has been real I think it
was like yeah I felt like my life didn't
really have purpose anymore because all
my life I had this like very clear
purpose and I guess I obviously still do
and I was following that purpose and it
was very like Centric around like my
family and my dad was like someone who
really was at the heart of that because
it was like okay he's encouraging me to
play the flute and then one day I'm
gonna be really successful at flu so I
can take care of him and that was the
focus it wasn't like I'm gonna be
successful at flute so I can win Grammys
I'm going to be successful at flu so I
can be a millionaire it was to take care
of him right so when he's gone it's like
my purpose was aimless and it was just
like the worst thing that could ever
happen to like a 20 year old like losing
your dad suddenly and not having
anywhere to live not having a job not
having anyone to talk to you know my my
family my mom and my sister were in
Denver trying to keep the family
business so I just was like
what if I just
left like I really had a the lowest
thought I had was like I just want to be
with my dad
and it wasn't like suicidal but it was
just like I'm exhausted with life
I am and what was it like living in a
car I mean what was the reality of that
at some point you would just what lay
down in your car and pull over by the
side of the road
gas station yeah and then at the time I
was still in my rock band so I was
fortunate to park in the
um where we used to rehearse the
rehearsal studios which was this like
Grody place in like Southeast Houston
roaches and everything but I could park
there and then I could like sleep in the
studio sometimes I slept on my drummer's
floor and like in his bedroom like next
to him like his bed was here and I was
on the floor and like when his family
would eat they would feed me and I was
like so grateful for that
um it was a lot of that in rotation
foreign